most of our out of the furnace oil don't
Menomonee through our had this young
reindeer herding girl is the heroine of
director Amanda Chanel's first feature
film Sami blood one of the three
finalists of the European Parliament Lux
film prize Sami blood follows a lap girl
determined to get the education she
craves despite the discrimination
against indigenous Sami people in the
1930s the Lascaris box thriller Western
follows a group of German construction
workers in a remote part of the
Bulgarian countryside and their tense
relationship with the locals BPM beats
per minute by director or van Campillo
looks at a group of act up activists in
France in the 90s and their fight to
draw attention to the country's AIDS
crisis it's already a hit a one Lacombe
play it can and has been chosen to
represent France at the Oscars now as
part of the lux film day's project the
films are translated into all of the
--use 24 official languages and screened
around Europe with live Q&A sessions
with cast and crew MEP s will vote for
their favourite film with the winner
announced in the ceremony in Strasbourg
in November
[Music]
you